so Andrew Tate recently converted to
Islam to be honest I've kind of had sort
of an American point of view whatever
thinking about it it's now that Andrew
Tate's converted it's really changed my
mind towards the whole religion and I'm
definitely going to look into it I have
nothing against Islam you're going to
look into it but you're not turning your
back on Jesus are you I'm just saying
I'm like I'm gonna do research into it
because if he is going into that
religion and I value his word so much
with everything else he's saying I'm
assuming it means something listen
nothing against it you're Sicilian well
I think a lot of people have been
following me for a while understand that
I've been very respectful of Islam for a
long time I was born in a Christian
country I was raised as a Christian and
I've always been very respectful of
Islam and it's become more and more
obvious to me and and more and more
pertinent that Islam is the last
religion on the planet when I talk about
Islam because I'm new to it yeah I I'm a
little bit careful right because I'm new
to it I'm certainly not a scholar
there's so much I need to learn I know
I'm on a Learning Journey I'm not here
to sit here and talk scripture I don't
know those things yet I'm here to learn
but when hear your assistance thank you
brother thank you thank you but um it's
just for me it feels like the last
religion on Earth I feel like there's no
other religion people say to me why did
you convert I said I don't really feel
it as a conversion I it's almost like I
knew God was real and now I've become
religious and they say oh you're
religious before I was like religious
before how Christian what does Christian
mean like who's not a Christian you go
to Christian nations and everyone says
they're a Christian look how they live
their lives go into the average church
is anyone actually fearful of God
anybody no the girls are out on Saturday
night drinking and they turn up to
church because their parents made them
but there's there's no substance to the
religion and also
Islam very closely reflects my personal
beliefs I through my personal life I've
learned that if you don't have standards
and you're not a strong person who's
prepared to defend his ideas you'll be
crushed yes and we look at most
religions in the world today which are
not prepared to defend their ideas
what's happened to them they're just
getting crushed and now we have
Christianity as an idea which is
basically said well we can't set any
firm rules because everyone will just
quit so instead let's make it so easy to
be a Christian that nobody has to put
any effort in and then accept everybody
no matter what and hopefully we can keep
the church's doors open do you not agree
with him to an extent with like this
religion I see why he thinks that I mean
I can see my in my youth so I I made all
of my sacraments in the Catholic church
but we didn't go to church every Sunday
we didn't sit at the kitchen table at
night and talk about the Bible or
biblical principles or or the stories
and how we can apply them to our own
lives we didn't we were like we phoned
it in all of it but it was extremely
important like when you had your baptism
communion confirmation every single
thing was so important and you had to
have a big party and the whole family
had to be there and we had to make a
fuss and you got all new clothes and
that day was was critical in your as a
stepping stone in growing up yet we
didn't really that was it that was yeah
you had a day where you put clothes on
like this is kind of his point and so so
I I do see his point though I now am a
practicing Christian and it is so very
important to me and so part of my daily
life like those things that go on like
while you're sleeping you know I'm on
the Bible app and I listen to the verse
the the verse of the day and then I read
the devotional and I listen to like
certain Christian artists songs that
really helped me feel connected and I go
to church and you know since we moved to
Florida I'm on the hunt for a new church
because I missed the one I fell in love
with in Boston so I'm a different kind
of Christian than the one he's talking
about for him to just make a
generalization about the whole religion
that the whole religion is is kind of
foolish and and a little bit ignorant I
think all to me is is strong God to me
is something to be feared God to me
something someone that people are afraid
to mock yeah God to me is someone that
you have to go out of your way to prove
something to God to me has red lines
like God to me represents the Islamic
faith the Christian God to me I don't
see God I can't explain I don't see
anything there so to me it was it was
the only logical Choice
I'm sure many people are like ecstatic
and extremely happy it's a great it's a
great thing for everyone honestly
because you know just anyone coming into
Islam is you know the prophet Muhammad
is better than the world and everything
in it but imagine now somebody of major
influence I mean you're the most Googled
person on the planet I'm not sure if you
still yeah I think Putin might have beat
me as of last week but I think it's
between me and Putin at the moment but I
don't want to lose the Putin Putin's the
Big G I don't want more enemies like
it's fine Vladimir you can have it I
never thought I'd hear you saying that
statement yeah
yeah I think where there's something
school but no no it's definitely
something beautiful and a lot of people
have you know you'll be surprised at how
many women as well like because
obviously the the accusations of
misogyny stuff which you know but but a
lot of women especially in the Muslim
world they're absolutely happy in fact
let me tell you a story just before I
came here today one um one particular
woman I can't remember her identity but
she's working as a school teacher yep in
London and um actually my friend told me
that she was uh kicked out of school
yeah because they had this campaign
against you in the schools I'm not sure
if you're aware of it yeah this was part
of the cancellation I didn't know about
this yeah so in in British schools they
said you know if you say anything good
about if you if you say anything good
about this person or you have to be
reported or prevented and if you say
anything you know you have to kind of
combat his extremism or whatever it may
be right so she because when you became
Muslim she abstained from doing that she
said I can't really do that because you
know Islamic laws and it's it's
backbiting and it's got honor and Islam
and so on and unfortunately they fired
her from that from the position wow so
you can see that this is the level of
encroachment we're talking about here so
and this shows you that the level of
fraternity that exists and not only the
fact that you know when you're looking
at Old Twitter or whatever Twitter or
whatever social media it's not a
representation of what's really
happening of course of course and I I
mean that's that's crazy to hear and
what's most crazy is
yeah the further behind this idea that
I'm somehow extremist is truly it's
truly clown world like I've sat as a
professional and analyzed my content and
understood which things can be taken out
of context and which things were said in
a way perhaps they wouldn't shouldn't
have been said before I was massively
famous but we have to sit here and
understand that if you take anybody on
the planet and give them seven years of
YouTube and then they decide and they
blow up big you're gonna be able to find
30 to 45 seconds of clip across all
those years that could be taken out of
context right yeah and and and and and
it's truly crazy because they sit and
say oh yeah but you know the young boys
are watching your stuff and they don't
truly understand all of it and it
there's Nuance that's missing and my
argument is very simple my argument is
well one you're taking small Clips out
of context and two there's not a single
piece of content on the internet that 14
year old boy can't misunderstand name
somebody name someone who's producing
content on the internet that you would
be a hundred percent happy for a 14 year
old drill artists and so they say that I
mean I live in an area this I'm not
going to mention the names of the artist
but they're talking about going to this
I know it is ironic because then you
just push rap and murder and all this
horrible [ __ ] on these kids and then
you're like Andrew take is the is the
one that's that's yeah the devil wild
cardi B did I show you this video
oh boy outside in my son's name because
I love him
my daughter's name
so now that I got my son's name on my
face I told also the bust nuts on this
side of my face because you know it's
kind of weird like don't touch this side
of the face touch this side of the face
you know what I'm saying like make sure
you don't buzz over here bust nuts here
she's the one going on like the kids
shows and [ __ ] like that this is the
this is the young girls of the young
girls are coming out to her yeah but the
young girls apparently smart enough to
decide that that's not a good role model
oh yeah they sure are it's so stupid
it's backwards some people recognize
when I convert to Islam that there was a
time I was an atheist there was a time
when I was atheistic and the reason I am
now so absolutely certain that God is
real is because I've seen evil I've seen
shaytan I've seen it when you see enough
evil you realize that there must be an
equal and opposite force and there are
people out there in the world today
doing the work of the devil genuine
demons who are trying to destroy the
Baseline morality that's inside of all
of us we're all born with some kind of
morality and they're trying to destroy
it and that's exactly the Islamic
understanding that we believe that you a
bone or something called fetra which is
the initial goodness you're you're born
with an innate belief receptivity to
believe in one God and then that is
corrupted in fact there's a prophet uh
Hadith of the Prophet where he says
every born child is born upon this
initial goodness
and then his for father and mother or
his parents they socialize him into you
know Christianity Judas and magism so
the idea is that everyone is born with
this initial uh goodness and this
initial will or want to believe in God
one God and then as you mentioned I mean
it's what you're mentioning here is
really is profound because you're you're
mentioning a central Doctrine in Islam
that is true and that that's a I think
that's a lovely belief I really like
that if that is true that all people all
humans are born with that then what what
happens is you know like these
Christians who he's talking about who
are totally lost and and have no
connection to their religion or any
religion or any God and they talk about
it but it's all just lip service you
know they they have that's still in them
and they have a chance to come back to
that I mean he he himself is 30
something years old and now just coming
to this so who is he to to pass judgment
on the Christians oh yeah I don't like
that and I saw the Quran and confirmed
so many things for me you know like even
the conversations I've been having so
far so many things have been confirmed
and it's amazing the knowledge that's
inside of it which is so applicable
today yeah for for a old book right you
know it's supposed to be old but it
seems so so Timeless but it's truly
amazing but you're you're totally right
and the Baseline morality I don't think
most people understand that when they're
doing this under the guise of Tolerance
when they're saying be so tolerant that
you no longer believe in right from
wrong they're not doing that to make
Society a better place they're doing
that to empty your brain so that you
have no resistance to the slave mind
programming they want to get you to a
point where if they tell you the sky is
green yeah you look at with your own
eyes yeah and you see blue but no the
sky is green that's what they want so
that you have to have nothing in your
brain that can prevent that if you have
God if you have no I believe this is
right and wrong if you have personal
responsibility if you have
self-accountability if you're a person
who sticks up for what he believes all
that's bad to them they want all of that
gone so they can tell you the sky is
green this may be a loaded statement
because I don't fully understand what
I'm talking about but maybe the
Christians the legit Christians and the
Muslims should get together you know for
political purposes collab stream they're
gonna collab they need to get together
and join forces and be able to you know
really stand for Traditional Values if
it doesn't because it truly doesn't
matter if you're following the Quran or
you're following a true biblical
principles they're very similar and
there's a lot there's enough similarity
that we can stand together to create
traditional solid values in American
culture again instead of all this
[ __ ] Madness that's turning it's
sending us down the toilet sitting here
[ __ ] on Christianity if he really
cared about those values he would look
around and say who can I align myself
with who can I who can I align with to
make sure that these values that we save
Society together understand why like the
thing is though I understand exactly why
he's saying it I hope his next step in
his in his evolution is to say and maybe
this isn't in the Muslim religion I
don't know there's a I know [ __ ] and the
Islamic is to come his next step as a
Muslim is to say who can realign
ourselves with to create the world that
we believe we want even if they are they
don't respond to our religion and and
you know what maybe this religion it's
like if you're not one of us like
everybody's everybody's burning in hell
no I hear both sides I I definitely do
but um from what I take from what he's
saying is like if he has to pick a
religion he's going to pick to a
religion that actually sticks has that
I'm talking about what's next like
getting these rules together you know
collab stream collapse yes collect yeah
and and if they're trying to program us
all into slaves and I remember when I
was in my undergraduate days and I was
uh reading a particular book by this guy
called Jeremy Bentham who became like
you know the spiritual forefather of
James Mill who is the father of like
social liberalism of today and I
remember reading this because it was so
powerful because it linked to something
I read in the Quran he said that you
know you have two gods
he said you have the god of pain and you
have the God of Pleasure and I thought
this is so interesting the Quran States
you know
have you seen the one who takes his own
desires as a God and because now there
is no transcendental force that we can
look up and as you say venerate now
we're forced to be slaves to the system
yeah we're to our own desires or I mean
the Quran has another verse which I
think is so powerful and it connects
very well with what you're saying
it says
that God has struck a parable of a man
that he's got many different slave
owners
and another kind of man who's only got
one slave owner he's God is basically
telling us in the Quran that you've got
one example of one individual who's got
multiple slave owners and another one
with just one he says are they the same
so here the idea is
as Rousseau said that his liberal
philosophy said that man is Born Free
but everywhere in Chains
this is the order because if you don't
have that God to to worship then you're
going to end up having to worship to
everything else and the whole part of
the shahada which you took which is uh
[ __ ] that's crazy what's crazy no if you
know this already you you church with me
and you heard I think it was 2 two or
three weeks in a row sermons from JD
about idolatry and about worshiping
false gods and how they're they're never
gonna they're never gonna fulfill you
you're always gonna fall short nothing's
ever going to work that is exactly the
same thing as here which kind of proves
my point that we have parallels no yeah
100 I definitely see all these but oh
you're bugging out on it again you
forgot I gotta remind you we're gonna
take you back and show you the
recordings of JD talking about that
because you liked it you came home and
you talked about it in the middle of the
week you you remember I remember you
saying you were thinking about it it's
an excellent point it is I just think
especially like a lot of regular
churches it's just like I don't get
anything out of it yeah the church we
went to back home was good yeah I know
but like for the most time like most of
the time it's just like some old ass
dude reading reading something that you
can't even hear um wow and then you
gotta stand up you gotta sing your songs
and it's just like what if I didn't gain
anything from this spiritually could
have read a book and and had more
insight right but but but to look at it
and understand and as you get older you
understand that that's just one
experience of it oh yeah I'm sure that
there's something you know and that's
why I'm on the hunt for the right church
here in Florida because I've been to
three so far because they're all
different and you've got to find the one
that that gets you where you're trying
to go with it but yes sitting and
listening to crusty 99 year old man may
be a great experience but gets it gets a
little it gets a little uh boring
sometimes and I don't know I had a
problem I found Catholicism I love it as
a culture because we're Italian and I
love the gold and the glitz of it but I
also find found it to be like very
disconnecting from God and very like he
says God should be feared and I'm like
that's what they did and I didn't it
didn't do anything for me I like the god
that like wants to sit down next to me
and get me through my [ __ ] and that's
where what I found with the Baptists so
I'm interesting this is interesting
because I like learning more about the
Muslims let's see what else they got to
say we've got two minutes
the true meaning of that is that there
is no God worthy of worship except for
one God which means that your your
desires or the system or these people
that want to control us they are the
problem is they're not worthy of worship
the only one worthy of our subordination
and submission is the creator of the
heavens and the Earth there's no one
else I agree and it's it's like a
Christian I completely agree and I've
agreed with this for the longest time
you know I've never been to like a music
concert and people ask me why and I said
I just look at it and I feel embarrassed
I look at someone up on a stage dancing
around and I look at hundreds of
thousands of peasants in the crowd just
yeah yeah yeah I'm like it's embarrass I
feel cringe it's like secondhand
embarrassment when I see these festivals
and everyone's losing their mind or
these music concerts what did I tell you
after I went to Rolling loud in New York
City oh you I think you said it was like
you just felt like a an NPC is that
right yeah they said I felt like a bot
after seeing card and I told you going
to festivals and stadiums socks it's no
way to see music going to a club and
theater shows you're really taking in a
different level of entertainment that is
very much more personal so he's not
wrong in in half the cases no not at all
genuinely feel embarrassed for the
people who go because to me that is a
form of worship like yeah you can listen
to the music at home for free like you
don't have to wait in that line and
stand out in the cold I don't know
perhaps it was a bit extreme but I've
always known that they're trying to give
us false Idols to some degree and when I
speak to atheists atheists they go I
don't believe in God but they they've
signed up so hard to the liberal woke
agenda they're as religious as anybody
but they're just believing in the wrong
things they're believing in degeneracy
and they're believing in the work of the
devil so humans always need something to
believe in and it's a great thing you
said about your own desires it's like
one one guy I was talking to since my
conversion says it's interesting that
somebody with everything all the Western
World yeah I think everything somebody
could want exactly has now converted and
I said yeah because even before my
conversion I understood that Hedonism is
a black hole and you can never fill it
you're never going to be able to have
enough girls to be happy with girls
you're never gonna be able to have
enough money to be happy with money you
know be able to you know drink enough to
be happy with drinking like it's a black
hole and you can pour endless things
down it but you'll never fill it up and
you need to have some degree of
self-restraint and I've always been a
very disciplined person I've never made
mistakes but certainly yeah the higher
power is is going to give you more
satisfaction in your heart than endless
endless Insanity so do you have any
final thoughts for for entertain
converting to the Islamic faith I don't
know I I just wish he would be easy
around Christians because you it were
out here and not all of us are just NPCs
in the Christian World some of us are
working hard of an NPC a main character
yeah some of us are main characters out
here trying to trying to trying to
change things and trying to make the
world a better place slow down on the
generalizations because it's just as
unfair as me saying that Muslims are all
terrorists
it's just as ignorant like I do agree
with him about a lot of the way like the
Christian faith is where it's just not
followed to like the extent that Muslims
follow the Islamic faith thank you guys
so much for watching make sure to join
the Discord in my bio so you can post
stuff for us to react to and I also have
some of my free social media tips there
for you to check out
gone
[Music]